and here to discuss that and the
extraordinary week in politics is Gabe
DeBenedetti national correspondent for
New York Magazine Gabe another quiet
week in the capital
yeah I want to start with the the
immunity deal for Alan Weisberg the CFO
of the Trump Organization we don't know
the details of this deal right but this
is a man who essentially knows
everything yeah it is important your
first point here is very important which
is we don't know the extent of his
cooperation or what he's willing to talk
about at all but this is a man who when
you talk to people that are familiar
with the Trump Organization the Trump
world overall they always say this is
the guy that you have to talk to more
than Michael Cohen more than in some
cases Donald Trump himself and he's
never been willing to talk
that's absolutely right he's been a very
quiet figure and a lot of people have
speculated that that's because of
loyalty out of loyalty to the family and
loyalty to the organization but now that
he's talking there are a lot of
questions about what he's willing to say
and what he's willing to fork over can
we go to Michael Cohen for a second
thought he once said that he would take
a bullet for the president and now you
have him entering into this deal what's
changed a lot of people are wondering
what is making the difference
yeah well it's one thing to say that and
it's another thing to be faced with the
prospect of a legal bullet you know
there is so much going on that he could
be forced to account for what we've seen
so far of course is just a tiny thread
of that with regards to this what has
turned into a campaign finance violation
discussion but we really haven't gotten
into the overall finances of the Trump
Organization the Trump Foundation and
what we saw with the initial cooperation
from Cohen is a suggestion that he's
gonna be willing to talk about a lot of
things we don't know it for sure but it
certainly seems as if he's opened the
door to you know a long time of talking
well in that pleat he specifically says
for the principle purpose of influencing
the election is is what the grounds of
he's acted on but what does that mean
and this larger probe yeah well that's a
good question we don't actually know if
it means anything with regards to the
Moller investigation and it probably
doesn't directly but what it does do is
it directly implicates the president in
a campaign finance violation that's very
similar actually to something that
happened a few years ago with John
Edwards when he was a presidential
candidate he was indicted but not
ultimately found guilty but what this is
is a pretty serious violation alleged
of these campaign finance laws the
question is you know where does this go
next and that's why a lot of people are
going to be watching you know what the
news is about who Michael Cohen is
talking to and about what specifically
Paul Manafort meanwhile convicted this
week on eight of 18 counts faces a
second trial in mid-september in DC does
does the conviction here on an eighth of
18 counts in any way change you think
the government's approach to the second
trial well the government has already
looked at the manna fort defense
strategy for the first trial and tried
to incorporate it into the way that
they're preparing for the second one
there's no doubt that it would sort of
be irresponsible for them not to do that
and we of course don't know if metaphor
it's going to be under even more
scrutiny after the second trial but
right now they're already taking all the
evidence in all of the public statements
by the way including from the president
who has said Manta Ford see good men
rolling it all up and that's the
strategy for the next one so should we
interpret that as a pardon the president
saying he feels very badly for pom
Airport you know we shouldn't we should
always be careful about interpreting
what this president has to say but there
is no doubt that there are a lot of
people in the White House and around the
president who have said essentially
listen if he's talking about someone
like this there might be a pardon in the
offing at some point what do you also
know that a lot of people around him are
saying don't go there so what do you
think the consequence is quickly gig of
a partner would I think it would be a
big political consequence there are a
lot of Republicans on Capitol Hill even
who would say that's one bridge too far
all right gave DeBenedetti thanks so
much Gabe thank you